let's talk about uh the perpetual fund
uh futures funding rate i don't think a
lot of people understand how this works
now all of a sudden there's a bitcoin
futures etf so let's take a little bit
of time and really kind of explain like
what is this perpetual uh futures
funding rate
yeah so it's perfectly you know
understandable to be a little confused
by derivatives we saw the other week uh
one of the you know so-called greatest
traders investors of all time michael
berry legendary uh you know main
character in the big short comes out and
says hey does to short bitcoin do you
need to be collateralized how does it
work you have to pay do you have to pay
a rate and so so michael berry doesn't
understand perpetual futures it's okay
if you don't and so we're you know we're
here to break it down so essentially uh
you know there's futures contracts like
you know what uh the standard commodity
markets have whether that's for any
commodity or bitcoin uh and that's you
know dated into the future and then with
bitcoin uh arthur hayes of uh you know
former ceo bitmex came out with the
perpetual futures contract so it's a
futures contract that never expires but
it essentially it rolls over about every
eight hours
and so what you see is in order to keep
this this market this derivatives market
where you can leverage up long or short
um so you can you can take you know a
10x leverage position which means if
bitcoin goes up one percent you're in
you're holding scout or your contract
value goes up by ten ten percent it's
it's just leverage on your uh on the
market and so to kind of balance these
books or to keep the price tethered to
the spot market where real dollars or
you know real dollars are trading
against bitcoin uh there's a funding
rate so if if the perpetual swap market
gets too overheated and there's too many
longs relative to shorts the longs are
going to pay the shorts uh a percent of
their their notional position size every
eight hours and so that's the funding
rate so when you see the
really high green spike
long positions are paying short
positions a pretty good amount of money
just just to hold their position and so
this kind of incentivizes the market to
stay tethered to what the actual spot
price is because everybody wants to be
long bitcoin naturally but if too many
people in the derivatives market are
long well then there's going to be a
really strong financial incentive to be
sure and so you can kind of see based on
where these these funding rates are what
the kind of the
maybe not the majority of the market but
what's kind of the the bias in the
derivatives market who's long who's
short and what side of is kind of more
over levered and so you know this is a
kind of a more zoomed up view and
recently when we were at like 66 000 i i
think i posted that chart and said hey a
little overheated here i think people
are getting getting a little greedy and
so you know this pullback it's not
anything uh anything fundamentally has
changed it's just you know derivatives
and leverage and human psychology and
greed get in the way and so that's
that's kind of the cost for this
pullback yeah and so when we look at
this kind of zoomed in version what's
fascinating to me is like you could
literally just clearly see there was a
massive spike in that uh that futures uh
kind of interest there i mean literally
it's just vertical uh in that big spike
on the far right and then what you can
see is very clearly outlined right
afterwards as the price decline and it
you know in some ways almost like uh uh
keep it simple stupid right it's like
look if you start to see this which you
you know uh so clearly called out of
like
there is still the possibility that we
get these kind of head fakes it's not a
long term or medium-term head fake but
definitely day-to-day price movements
can be affected by these futures and now
we've almost added more complexity
because you have this bitcoin futures uh
etf you've got more people who are going
to start speculating in the market and
if you overlay that with a price break
of the previous all-time high everyone
just gets levered along real fast and
thinks that we're going to go you know
straight to 100k but
of course you know the the most
entertaining outcome is the uh is always
the outcome and so we get uh we get a
little bit of a price depression before
we then you know most likely go upwards
from here
yeah and here's like the interesting
thing with with these funding rates
right is like so you know most people
trading this stuff if you're in the
bitcoin derivatives market you're you're
most likely a bitcoin you're most likely
a crypto bull right yeah you know where
this is going you have a significant
stake in this asset uh you're bullish
long term but when funding spikes like
this um what you can do and a lot of
people do do this um you can you can go
mark it short with you know just a small
amount of your portfolio and you're
getting paid like sometimes when when
you this is you know this spikes this
funding rate you can get paid 30 50
sometimes 80 annualized just by being
short and and you're just hedging right
you're not you're not short your entire
portfolio you're just short with just a
small amount of derivatives and you can
be almost like in a market neutral kind
of way you know you're long and you're
just short with a small percent of your
portfolio and you're and you're
basically harvesting this kind of yield
right um that that the longs have to pay
their shorts to keep their position open
and so this you know the funding rate is
you know it's kind of this this uh you
know genius and invention by arthur
hayes like this financial market
innovation
but it's just kind of a way for for the
speculators to stay balanced a little
bit yeah it's fascinating when we look
at the futures open interest explain
this one
yeah so um a couple people i saw on my
feed they were they were saying hey you
know be wary uh bitcoin broke it's all
time high but look the the futures open
interest it's it's right below it's
all-time high things are getting a
little frothy um and and they're correct
the the the open interest is not near
out you know an all-time high but
there's a couple things under the
surface yeah which which is why you know
there's a big difference between where
we were in april and where we are today
that i think are are kind of significant
that aren't really understood um and the
biggest thing is uh the percent of open
interest that's that's margin with
bitcoin that's collateralized with
bitcoin so so open interest you you're
basically um you pledge collateral to
enter these contracts whether that's uh
you know a perpetual swap futures
contract or just uh you know say march
2022 futures contract give to pledge
collateral and you can do that with
bitcoin or you can do that with stable
coins and so at the top of the market in
april uh so even though we're at an
all-time high at the top of the market
in april what you saw was like 70 of
that open interest was collateralized
with bitcoin so as the price drew down
not only was your p l your profit and
loss in the position drawing down but
what you also saw was your collateral
was drawing down so that leads to a
pretty explosive dynamic where uh you
know the long side of the trade gets
gets uh gets wrapped basically and so um
now with cme uh this future's etf coming
in
and just you know
not like not so much uh like with
finance say you know there's not as much
bitcoin derivative or bitcoin
collateralized derivatives and it's more
like stable coins like tether and so
this leads to far less kind of you know
explosive long liquidations and actually
more short squeezes so this is kind of
you know this is fundamentally why the
the futures market the the kind of the
dynamic here even though it's close to
all-time highs is quite different it's
because like under the surface the
makeup of these these contracts is is a
lot different and that's that leads me
to be bullish um you know if if we see
this this spike in a significant way
it's kind of a sign that things are
getting a little frothy uh kind of a
little a little toppy in my opinion when
you look at this uh one that we have
here with the bitcoin uh margined uh
futures interest
the 70 and 45 is that kind of uh a good
reading of like the band that this
trades within uh normally or are those
kind of outlier type uh high points and
low points
yeah so it's i mean it's still just such
a nascent market um you know and it's
like every single day um just like with
the futures etf coming in right um
there's just there's so much capital
that that's coming in and really like we
don't have a you know a large precedent
back in the day when when arthur
launched uh the first count with bit
next in the perpetual swap market uh
basically everything was bitcoin
derivatives because we didn't have there
wasn't really like any sort of stable
coin there was no fiat on ramps to these
derivative exchanges all you had to use
was bitcoin and so now you know with
more regulated stable coins like usdc um
and an increasingly like derivative
exchanges popping up all over the world
with tether um you see kind of this
dynamic change a little bit and so this
is a very very healthy development for
the market i think the cme futures the
paper futures uh we talked about a
little bit when i was on the show last
time um even though people think it'll
lead to price suppression or all this
other stuff i actually think it's quite
good because it means that these these
kind of drawdowns that you see
throughout the history of bitcoin that
sometimes are very very volatile um i
think we're going to see less of that
because of of the you know the makeup of
this derivatives market and when you
look at the exchange bitcoin futures
open interest uh we've got it here kind
of broken down across the different
exchanges is there anything that we can
read into this other than just like
where do people want to go where's kind
of the most popular venue uh or there
are other kind of takeaways from this
yeah the biggest takeaway is and i don't
have a chart of this over time but the
biggest takeaway is that cme is now the
leading open interest derivatives
exchange futures exchange and this was
this is like a very very new dynamic and
it just kind of shows you um i forget
off the top of my head what this was
looking like a couple weeks ago but i
think i at the all-time high for cme
open interest was like uh you know three
billion at the market top and it was
trading around a couple a couple billion
and so this just kind of shows you like
in a week with just one atf product and
now the second one starting to trade
today is 5.6 billion um there's so much
demand for this for this product is so
much you know
financial demand to come get exposure in
any you know any sort of way to bitcoin
um and so now that with the cme leading
uh these derivatives markets um it's a
new interesting development um and it's
and it's also interesting because you
can't short you can't use bitcoin as
collateral on cme and so you can't long
with with bitcoin you can't long your
longs which kind of led to april and the
follow-up may crash being just so
explosive um that doesn't exist anymore
and when you short you actually have to
short with dollar collateral so you have
to keep pledging collateral which which
is bullish which is actually leads to uh
explosive court squeezes so um just an
interesting dynamic i mean i'm gonna
keep watching it but uh cme and you know
kind of american institutions are really
showing they want bitcoin exposure